for the audience who doesn't know what
it is to be a libertarian what is a
libertarian to you
somebody who believes that we each have
the right to make our own choices and
that society works much better if we can
each interact voluntarily rather than
having the government be in charge of us
okay so you would say so make our own
choices so so far that doesn't seem very
controversial everybody would say i want
to be able to make my own choices for
myself now you're saying that the both
the democrats and the republicans
want to make choices for you oh
absolutely just look at the recent
covid and schools when it just broke my
heart how mothers were going before
school boards
begging please teach my child in person
please
don't make them wear a mask they're
getting behind socially they're getting
behind educationally and
there was no choice because it was a
monopolistic system so let's just say
during covet we had joe jorgensen as our
president how different would things
have been oh like night and day let's
let's hear it i'm curious uh no mask
requirements of course
no business shutdowns and what a lot of
people don't realize they say well it
was so good though that we shut down the
economy so that people didn't get sick
but you have to look at
politicians being politicians of course
they allowed the big box stores to be
open they let the big guys be open it's
the small mom and pop stores that they
shut down so you know people think well
we need politicians we need government
to help the little guy
but it's actually government that's
hurting the little guy and what's very
distressing uh hearing the message from
the left i would love to explain to
everybody on the left who says corp you
know big corporations are bad we need to
cut them down to size well
big corporations are big because of
government
it's it's because government is giving
them special privileges and powers and
money can you can you go even a little
bit deeper than us so let's stay there
okay covey it is kobe 20 20. so
uh would an anthony fauci be there under
a pres under your presidency would we
have a surgeon general
that would come out or somebody from the
cdc or somebody from the nih that would
come out and say well here's what's
going on with covet here's what we got
to look at with this here's we got to
get the vaccine it's going to take us 9
to 18 months how different would you
have been that urgent would you have
shut down travel restrictions coming in
from china would you have restricted
people coming in from europe for the
period that we had what were some of the
decisions you would have made
no i would not have restricted people
and there would be no anthony fauci
uh giving edicts
it's one thing to have
a medical
unit as an advisory committee
it's another though to allow them to be
making decisions for instance the cdc
was basically making decisions on rent
on whether or not you could affect
attendance that's such an overreach of
what it was intended
okay but go a little deeper for me if
there wouldn't be an anthony fauci who's
given us updates and what are we
learning so you're a medical doctor your
medical doctor so so how about if i
can't afford medical because i don't
have a medical doctor who's telling me
what to do with covet oh we could spend
two hours just on medicine so if i could
divert there a lot of people say you
know capitalism isn't working so we need
to have uh you know
one size fits all we need to have
socialized medicine
well we don't
have capitalism in medicine what we've
got is we do have so many rules and
regulations that uh
that we're not getting the competition
needed and the biggest example would be
insurance a lot of people say well
insurance is too high well that's
because it's not insurance
what if your car insurance paid for
oil changes getting your car washed and
putting gas in your car
you wouldn't go around looking for the
cheapest gas station because what do you
care
uh insurance companies going to pay for
it anyway
and then
the next year your
premiums are going to go up because
the insurance companies are going to
have to raise prices because you weren't
looking for the cheapest option right
now there's absolutely no incentive to
look for the cheapest option in fact
i gave birth to both my daughters in a
birthing center and it was basically a
three-bedroom house
uh that had a kitchen you even had to
bring your own food
excuse me and this was in the 1980s
and i think it was like 900 and that and
you know you get the doctor and i
remember telling a friend of mine like
wow you know the birthing center and
only 900
and she said oh but i want to go to the
new women's center
uh and and there just been this big
story about how they had redone it and
they had 600
uh bed spreads
and i don't remember how many thousands
of dollars it cost but no skin off of
their nose
so and and now i realize that's an
extreme that's a higher
um that's at the higher end
but even just going into the doctor for
a checkup or going in because you have
an ear infection
uh that should that that would be a lot
cheaper than taking your car and if we
can take our car in for a 300
uh
repair then why can't we go to the
doctor and get you know 90 checkup but
but
dr joe let's go back to it so it's kovid
so there's no one that's going to give
me updates on what's going on with kobit
we're not shutting down fine i like that
we're not
closing travel coming in from china so
well do you mind if i interrupt please
and i
you said nobody is giving updates
uh the free market would definitely be
giving updates i mean we've got
companies now who are giving us updates
about about other things out there
so
why wouldn't some why wouldn't there be
some let's say
mcdonald's of healthcare who was saying
give putting advertisements on tv saying
okay this is what the latest research is
showing you need to come to our clinic
for
whatever to get tested whatever so
no we get a lot of
information in the free market in fact
look at all the information we get off
the internet if i may yeah oh please
yeah so
your president we know we know it's a
pandemic and it's coming fast and heavy
what would your administration response
be to a populist that is scared to death
of this word pandemic and they're
hearing it coming what would we have
heard from your administration
in terms of a national response because
this isn't just bad flu season this is a
pandemic well okay but let's back up
part of the reason there was so much
fear was because the government put the
fear in people if you look at college
age kids high school kids the death rate
for this was actually lower than the flu
for younger people even lower than that
you don't get up to the death rate of
the flu until you get much older so
again would we be doing this for the flu
would we be shutting everything down
would we be calling it a pandemic like
that that's what i was getting back to
is asking you to just kind of elaborate
for us and pat's question about so you
would have been as our president coming
to the microphone saying hang on a
second we're using the word pandemic but
you would have then said well wait wait
but but but who put the word pandemic
out there to begin with
it was the president it was the
government so i'd be coming out there
saying as you've seen in the news we've
got this new uh
we've got this new disease going around
we've got this new virus
and i would act as a leader
not as a king i would act as a leader
telling people you know
go to your medical professional go to
your doctor
go to now of course under a libertarian
administration
if we had fixed health care to the point
to where it wasn't a monopolistic system
because that gets back to you know we
talk about high cost
doctors are a government-run monopoly
the government grants
how you know indirectly grants how many
people can get nds and how many people
can practice i mean if they did that for
plumbers and car mechanics
that would be sky high too so
if we had different people out there
providing services an increase in nurse
practitioners and so on it would be much
cheaper and we could easily say go to
your health care provider so i think
i i relate to some of the
you know elements of libertarian i do i
fully relate to it i get it
but for me it feels like to do what you
want to do
if you were president 2020 it would be a
mess
and here's
it was totally a mess but let me explain
to you why i think it would be even a
bigger mess
because i think to do
what you want to do or even inject that
spirit
don't you think it makes more sense to
start from congress
senate governor and work your way up to
have other people that are
infrastructure that are
like if i were to ask you right now how
many of our congressmen are libertarians
registered libertarians how many would
there be oh none how many senators do we
have that are registered
you're not gonna you don't have you
don't have poll so okay let's just say
you're president you wouldn't get
nothing done in today's system though
but in today's system let's just say if
you were to become president
in today's system
who's going to back you up from the left
to the right
they have a monopoly today except if i
were president then there would also be
incoming senators and congress people
because it's not going to be one person
getting elected out of everybody it's
going to be a movement there are going
to be other people you really think that
somebody's going to elect a third party
president and only the president's going
to be liberating i think i think no i
don't think that i think uh uh
you know i think the movement is gonna
need help from different places i do
believe that but you also need backing
now don't get me wrong the first the
best third-party candidate of all time
is who abraham lincoln he's the first
republican right he was third party came
up home you can tell the teddy roosevelt
story right on what he did you can go
look at ross parole you know people will
throw george wallace in there ron paul
and there's a lot of names that they'll
throw into
uh best third party candidates right but
wouldn't it make sense to
go
and get others internally
converted rather than going straight to
the top because if you can pull up some
of the numbers so some will say the
following some will say
uh president biden is president today
because of you
he's meaning and they would be wrong but
go ahead but i would show you the
numbers some would say that you're the
reason why president biden is president
no pull up the numbers i just texted you
pull up the numbers i just take city i
don't know if you have that or not if
you can put it on this well like for
instance i did beat the spread in
several states for instance pennsylvania
i did beat the spread but what you would
have to say is something like 80 85
percent of the people who voted for me
all would have gone to trump and that's
not the way it would have gone we tend
to get votes from both sides so it may
be if every single vote i got went to
one person but that's not the way it
works well more more libertarians would
probably align themselves with a
trump than they would with a body that's
not what the research shows we draw
equally from democrats and republicans
you think so
that that's what the research shows
absolutely so you know
what i was doing was i was basically
going to be answering your question
uh
look at cannabis
uh reform that's libertarian and that's
on the left look at marriage equality
where gays are allowed to get married
that's libertarian and that's on the
left um abortion although i tend to not
you know that that's an issue that i
stay away from and there
ron paul
made a libertarian argument for being
pro-life so you know i
that that's a very inflammatory so but
but that would be where um democrats and
the libertarian party uh would agree on
immigration i mean you go right down the
line there are many people who come over
from the left and i've talked with many
of them in fact i met with somebody at
bitcoin yesterday
who v very interesting story he was on
the left
and then he went to a diversity class
and the professor
at at a college and the
he was the only
male in the class
and he's or maybe a white male but the
professor said if you are a white male
there is a 100 chance that you're going
to rape somebody and he was just
appalled so he immediately became a
conservative
but then he didn't like some of those
ideas and then he found out about the
libertarian party he said okay that's me
so
go ahead tom
no that's i was going to ask is to
describe the typical dem that would come
across and the typical republican would
come across who were those voters
because we've learned about that
identity politics that we see through
the media doesn't really define anybody
but then we discover with a lot of
democratic
demographic acuity like what happened to
terry mcauliffe when the mothers of
children in virginia were so incensed on
the level of control over the education
of their kids and we can see that it was
all races but this the common stripe was
women with children under eighth grade
really flipped out and turned on him and
so that's what i was looking for is
groups like that that you can describe
it's like young people that are at
public schools but that came from public
education with this and this i didn't
know if there was like
typical
you know
kind of an archetype for these voters
you talked about issues but i was kind
of curious about the people groups and
typicalities such as moms of kids under
8th grade of all races and economic
backgrounds attacked terry mcauliffe and
he was not governor of virginia right
and i was so glad to see him leave
now
unfortunately you mentioned kids in
public schools and if we extend that to
college unfortunately most of them are
going to the left and
we gotta we got to put a stop to that
problem in fact i
am
part of the founding of an organization
of libertarian educators
to trying to get together to see okay
how can we stop this how can we get in
there and because
you know something like 92 96
of professors lean to the left
and we've got to get in there and show
them and opposing
a more sane
alternative if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]